did I call it or did I call it here's a
tweet it's an excerpt from that story in
a March meeting Laura demlow an FBI
official warned the threat of subversive
information on social media could
undermine support for the U.S government
do you think Luke I gotta imagine you're
trying really hard every day to
undermine support for the US government
but uh I'll keep reading Dem Lo
according to notes of the discussion
attended by senior Executives from
Twitter and JPMorgan Chase stressed that
we need a media infrastructure that is
held accountable this is what I was
saying that the reason Elon tried
backing out is because they showed him
confidential information saying we have
these Arrangements of the federal
government and you can't disclose it
and you now have to buy it and Elon
probably was like no way dude no wait
now maybe that's not the case but what I
did get right was that Twitter was
actively working with the government on
what they deemed to be National Security
issues albeit bunk once what may have
happened now because also I won't say I
I got 100 correct what may have happened
after this Elon Musk buys Twitter
now he's leaking information you guys
see this the evidence that they withheld
information on fraud or whatever he
posted this tweet of the guy being like
basically we're doing what elon's
accusing us of doing and the information
was withheld from the courts I think
Elon gets Twitter
the Obama I'm sorry the Biden well Obama
the Biden Administration panics
they leaked this information because
they know Elon is now sitting on a trove
of evidence and he probably will publish
it or it will get leaked and they can't
control it anymore yeah he he knows how
the federal government manipulated the
the in the public landscape manipulated
the elections manipulated National
tragedies manipulated what happened in
Afghanistan manipulated what happened
with with covid that that's a treasure
Trove of information that he has as his
fingertips right now that could show us
the direct manipulation by government
the direct manipulation and interference
of government when it came to of course
destroying free speech in this country
and again I've been screaming about this
for years and everyone's always was
saying but it's a private company it's a
private company I still remember you
know even three years ago being on the
show and then there was a guest saying
but there's a private company they get
to do what they want and I was like
they're not a private company they were
never a private company they always had
connections with the federal government
they are a proxy of the U.S government
exactly and the special interests who
control the US government that actually
pull the strings of the bureaucrats
inside of Washington DC and then people
we need to realize this is this is real
this is absolute real life crazy
conspiracy that that has turned out to
be true a week before the election let
me tell you guys
we hear from from the left the Democrats
they're like this election is could be
the death of democracy like if the
Republicans win the Republic is over
whatever well they don't say Republicans
say the death of democracy I genuinely
believe it this story got exposed that
this election very well may be a battle
for the soul of the Republic to which
I don't even know if Republicans can
save it to be completely honest but
certainly Democrats are going to rip it
to shreds and the last line of defense
is going to be some of these Maga
Republicans who might actually push back
against this but let me put it this way
they started this campaign after the
2016 election
we then saw how the media was
manipulating we saw all of it we saw the
lies about Donald Trump constantly
social media censorship the Banning of
Alex Jones and Milo yiannopoulos project
veritas
they are doing this specifically
because they want to manufacture consent
the Democrats have controlled Congress
since 2018. this has been ramping up
Trump signed the sisa act around 2018
with Democrats in control
if they retain control of Congress these
programs will manipulate and subvert
public discourse manufacture consent and
interfere with our elections
if there is not an effort in any way I
don't know I'm not saying Republicans
are guaranteed to do anything about it
but they're certainly the only ones who
are able to
if this isn't if the Democrats win this
is going to ramp up tenfold and then
that's it but hold on I want to I want
to kind of question that a little bit
because it was Donald Trump who put this
into place right and if you're a
republican coming into power right that
that that's like a the Ring of Sauron
right here you have the ability to to
navigate and control speech online you
have the possibility to fortify
elections why would Republicans give out
that power because it consumes you
exactly yeah but why I don't I don't
trust the Republican party I mean not
the leadership there are good
Republicans there are good members and
they're good candidates running this
cycle but what I struggle with is you
know here we go again we've had wave
elections in this country before 1994
2010 2016 we had the trifecta you know
White House both both chambers of
Congress and here we are again we're
talking about another wave election well
where did those three previous wave
elections get us right here so what's
going to be different about it this time
you know if we take the house you know
we'll have Kevin McCarthy speaker if we
take the Senate we'll have Mitch
McConnell as majority leader and I'm not
saying it's a good thing to have the
Democrats in full control for two more
years but you know I just want to hear
how this is going to be different this
time I agree and what frustrates me to
no end is we we don't treat our voters
with respect we don't treat the
right-leaning people in this country our
constituents we don't have the humility
to look them in the eye and say hey yeah
what we've been doing has been failing
and we're going to try something
different I don't see them doing
anything different but that that's just
me that's my own perspective yeah I mean
there's there's Thomas Massey there's
Margaret Taylor green there's Rand Paul
there are great members they may if the
Republicans get in they may be able to
make some look it's the best chance we
got especially in the house there's some
great numbers on the house side the sin
is a different story but unless unless
your proposal Lucas I don't know vote
libertarian it's a unit party two head
it's it's two heads of the same snake at
the end of the day just we also have to
understand our our public opinion
matters on this what we say what we
think how we respond to this story how
we share this story absolutely matters
and I say that specifically because if
you remember not so long ago the Federal
Government tried to pass the
disinformation government board and they
had a disinformation czar that they were
putting forward essentially what they
were trying to do is codify what they
were doing in secret and then the wide
response to that was hell no are you
crazy you want to control speech in this
country you're insane but now we're
finding out oh yeah they were just doing
it the whole time but under a
sub-organization of the DHS under cisa
that's the organization that was doing
this that's the organization doing this
now so so we have to understand they're
only doing this in secret because that's
the only way that they could get away
with this right now we need more of a
bigger pushback and again left right I I
think we we shouldn't be consumed with
parties we shouldn't be consumed by
making Mass generalizations about
individuals based on their gang and
their affiliation we should focus on the
individual if an individual is good we
should support them if an individual
sucks and as a corporate distance as a
banker and is a little sellout status
shell that will screw you over
don't support that person I don't think
the solution is in the government though
I think that as always in the United
States it comes from the public the
private sector the people that are
willing to build systems that adhere to
the U.S Constitution the government's
there to protect us if things go wrong
um and I think social media in general
you're never going to be able to ask it
stop manipulating stop manipulating
things stop it's never going to stop
it's there for the world the problem
with free systems is they're easy to
manipulate they're easy to hijack so
that's one kind of flaw in the United
States freedom and democracy it lets
people come in and just twist it around
and say whatever they want and that's
red communism and spread
authoritarianism and so that's
oh oh I I think that uh oh anyway
continue yeah okay that's actually
actually one of the big conspiracy
theories of history is that
the British didn't actually surrender
the Revolutionary War they realized that
we were attempting to build a government
of foreign by the people and they said
whoa wait we can we can Finance control
of this of the of the colonies we don't
need to do anything and they really did
the central banks they warned us that
the central banks are more dangerous
than standing armies and
over the years they've tried there's a
third one that they've installed in the
United States what was it Andrew Jackson
got shot after he broke up the second
one he did uh I don't just finished a
grade biography yeah I mean he was a
hero I mean imagine imagine abolishing
the federal bank and being in office
with a federal Surplus not a debt a
surplus I mean the big controversy in
his administration was had to distribute
the Surplus amongst the states imagine
that yeah imagine that and then they put
him on the 20 bill but but you're
talking about something here that's very
important here because this DHS board
this information board was also working
to of course make sure that information
wasn't being released that would
undermine our financial institutions
inside of the United States and Trust in
the financial institutions that
literally have bankrupted this country
it's not a recession It's a Robbery
what's happening right now with the
banks and what they've done to the
American public yeah they have to really
hate us I imagine like Ian Grant ragging
on the Federal Reserve 24 7 Luke as well
well how does this show exist some
people just want to end it all and
they'll be like take it down to burn it
to the ground but item not like that and
I'm one of like make a better system so
that we can transition away from the
Federal Reserve into like a
decentralized system of banking you know
the great thing about the Federal
Reserve is if someone robs it and takes
your money they'll cover it FDIC
Insurance like if if your bank if you
lose your bank card you can go get
another one with crypto if you lose your
keys all your crypto's gone forever you
have nothing if someone steals your
crypto out of your wallet you're you
have nothing yeah and there's no
recourse very dangerous for like the
common man I understand why there's
reticence but at the same time like it's
like pick your poison do you want Total
overarching Control authoritarianism or
do you want fully decentralized laissez
faire good luck out there lifestyle I
don't you know I don't maybe there's a
middle ground I probably want a middle
ground
um but who's going to be who would be in
control of the crypto wallets who would
be there to be like I'll make sure I'll
be the one that'll hold your keys for
you I think anything's better right now
than the current system we have now
where the government literally prints
money and just hands it to the richest
people in the world I I think
specifically the people who you know
promote the ESG score and use that kind
of Leverage and Power in order to push
woke nonsense onto people that that
should be pushed back on but again a lot
of it is coming from top down
corporations that get a lot of money
from the Federal Reserve I agree Luke
they should not be printing money and
giving it to the rich people richest
people in the world they should be
printing the money and giving it to me
then then I'd be totally okay with it
right you know just just give me the
money and then we're good because
because that's the way that's a lot of
people do think like that yeah that's
exactly how people think everybody
thinks that they have all the answers
and actually interestingly it tends to
be that the only answers come from
decentralization when everyone is
actually arguing and then the ideas that
make the most sense rise to the top and
then end up succeeding yeah there's like
value to like minimal centralization
like nodes of centralization all over
the price proliferative you know like
you don't want more than 60 people
involved in a note or something like
that but Tim what you're mentioning
right now is extremely important and
exactly what the Department of Homeland
Security is preventing they're
preventing the best ideas from going out
there they're preventing you know
Solutions they're preventing a lot of
this nonsense to be stopped in our lives
the pain and suffering that a lot of
people are going through is because of
the disinformation out there that they
are spewing actively and they are not
fighting it they are making sure that
they are codifying their agenda their
narrative which goes against you and
everyone else that's a great point
because you know that's the that was the
original concept of our government was a
very decentralized system with very
little uh you know power uh you know
vested in a central government the
states could be the the incubators of
Liberties I think someone one of the
founders said but of course the the
powers that be they understand that when
people are presented with you know the
truth with an opposing narrative they're
attracted to it you know it gets them
thinking and it reduces their own power
so they have to squash it and that's
what we're seeing with this story that's
what we've seen for the past six years
you know on steroids and it's it's never
going to stop until they feel the
consequences
um you know of of of that decision
they've made thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there